well the atmosphere couldn't be more
different than it was three days ago
this was all a flame with barricades
hundreds of thousands of protesters
manning these barricades to stop the
police the riot police from coming down
from behind where we are now and of
course the snipers up in the buildings
picking off and causing so many deaths
in that crucial clash three days ago now
it's a much more somber the damage is
everywhere of course but much more
somber event people are still coming
there are candles everywhere there are
some larger shrines but also anywhere
there's a space people have put candles
in memory of those that have died and
also plenty of signs that they're ready
to bring this back up again should they
need to look at this here there's wood
this is for fires so they can keep
braziers man they can set fire to
barricades again if they want to all the
bricks are piled up they can break them
apart and turn them into makeshift
missiles at a moment's notice uh also
down here
you can see that these enclosures now
have been set up now this enclosure if
we're right with these flags that are
above it with the stars around on a blue
drape that's the european party of
ukraine just one sign of one of the
small agendas they've got going here in
the square now clearly looking west as
far as this group of people are
concerned see the stretchers all lined
up here as well this is in case that
things turn nasty again in the way uh as
they did three days ago and further down
people much more organized you can see
the
the firewood's been split uh ready to
keep these boilers going so that the
crowds that come here both those that
are manning the barricades but also
those that um
come down to visit square can find food
that can find coffee and so you see
people here queuing up to get themselves
or something
they're always anxious to engage with us
unity
came out of prison after two and a half
years of being imprisoned in the east
came forwards made the claim that she
might like to be president very mixed
reactions even those two guys we spoke
to there some of them saying yes we want
her back as president we trust her
others saying still no she's part of the
old order and we want something new so
how is the politics playing out now well
let's head east
my colleague david bowden is in the city
of kharkiv where it's believed that
president yanukovych fled
after this peace deal with the
protesters was agreed on friday but
david what's the atmosphere like now in
ukraine's second city
well it's kind of business as usual here
andrew but
there are two
smallish protests one uh you can see
behind me which is basically around
lenin's statue
they don't want the
pro-government the new government
protesters to come and take down this
statue as they have done in other parts
of ukraine so they're defending it they
say that
they believe this new government is
illegal and they want to go back to the
old regime not necessarily because they
support yanukovych but because they
don't believe the new order is the way
forward 200 yards up the road from then
is a counter protest of the new
government the people who want to see
the west become more involved in ukraine
they are in the municipal buildings here
uh some of them slept there we're told
they again have their peaceful protest
so it's ongoing they're kind of marking
time if you like meanwhile everybody
else the buses are coming and going here
in the middle of the city as people go
about their business and go to work
andrew
david thanks very much indeed david
bowden there in khaki if you can see the
sound stage here still set up it's been
going all night they've had prayers this
morning there are cameras there waiting
to record more of the speeches mikhail
sakashvili the former president of
georgia was here last night offering his
support as the former leader of one
other satellite nation that's had its
difficulties with russia since trying to
claim some sort of independence so
support is coming in from uh estates
nearby as well as from the european
union and the united states as well
baroness ashland the european union
foreigner she should be here today to
meet with high level officials and the
interim president to see what kind of
way forward they can manage so the
politics is very focused remember they
have promised to pull together something
of an interim parliament an interim
government by tuesday which doesn't give
them much time